Allah Allah herkese Merhabalar Öncelikle
kendi heyecanım yenebilmek için size bir
soru sorarak başlamak istiyorum Atom
nedir bilmeyenler elini Kaldırabilir mi
Atom nedir bilmeyenler
bu peki bir soru daha soracağım başka
sormayacağım söz söz Elektron nedir bu
sefer de bilenler elini Kaldırabilir mi
muhteşem bayağı çok kişi biliyor peki
şimdi ben bilmeyenler ya da tam
hatırlamayanlar için bir ufak bir şey
yapayım burada maddenin yapı taşı atom
diyoruz bir tane çekirdeği var
çevresinde böyle ki onlar yörüngelerde
dönüyorlar Eğer ki kimya derslerine çok
uyumadıysan ız Lisede Bir de Derler ki
aslında öyle görünce falan yok onun
yerine böyle bir elektron bulutu var Bu
elektronlar yörüngelerde dolanırlar da
bu şekilde bir bulut ayında olasılık
bulutu halinde duruyorlar şurası buldu
demek ne demek çok da önemli değil ama
olasılık Bulut olmasının sebebi kuantum
mekaniğini Ben de şimdi Fizikle ilgili
bir konuşma verirken hiç kuantum
demezsem herhalde başım Yanar da onun
için söyledim ve bu konuyu kapatmış
olduk
Evet şimdi Güldüğüne göre rahatladım Ben
de asıl anlatmak istediğim hikaye
geçeyim anlatmak istedim hikaye kişisel
bir hikaye Normalde kişisel hikâyeleri
fazla önem vermiyorum doğru bulmuyorum
bilim insanı olarak Çünkü tekil tekil
hikayeler bize motive edebilir Ama
Kollektif olarak istatistikçi anlamlı
olmayabilir Yani mesela Sizin Amcaoğlu
sirke ile kendi iyileştirilmiş olur ama
bu sirkenin genel olarak işe yarayacağı
anlamına gelmez Dolayısıyla Normalde tek
tek hikayeler derse kolektifleri
toplayıp ona göre karar vermeyi bilimsel
olarak daha doğru buluyorum ama şimdi
bugün bir hikaye anlatacağım hem de
kişisel bir tane yapacağım Çünkü bazen
de çok Ender çok nasıl bir sıra dışı bir
baka size kendi hipotezlerin izi sorgula
atabilir Neyi nasıl bildiğiniz ilgili
acaba burada bir tekrar düşünmem
gerektirir onun için böyle bir kişisel
hikaye var ve bu Güçler hikayede ben
kendimi anlatacağım Nasıl fizikçi oğlum
fiziki ne demektir diye birazcık bundan
söz edeceğim hikaye
Ben 15 dakikada ns18 dakika sığması için
nasıl bir şey olması lazım böyle uzun
uzun bakmak bir yıl Bunu düşündüm Sonra
yavaş yavaş olgunlaştım falan diyemem
Böyle hoşunuza gidecek tek tek Karlar
göstermemişti Neyse Oğlan'ın kıza ilk
gördüğü an veya işte kılıcını çekip ata
bindiği an falan gibi birşey olması
lazım Benim de birinci anım Şu an şu
kitapla dedemin kütüphanesine
karşılaştırma yeryüzü ve gökyüzü diye
bir kitap yıllar sonra doktor yaptığım
sırada öğrendim ki bu kitabın yazarı
aynı zamanda gördüğünüz bu kırmızı kaplı
hepimizin liseden bilgi atlasında yazarı
olan kişi mi Faik Sabri Duran Bu kitabı
çok etkilenmiş olmalıyım Çünkü kitabı
okudukça onun içerisindeki işte ya
gökyüzünde gördüğümüz galaksiler
Yıldızlar işte yerde gördüğümüz
volkanlar hesabını o kadar beni
etkilemiş olmadı ki bunlarla ilgili
notlar almaya başladım sudan bana diyor
ki böyle notlar alarak olmaz Bunları bir
yere getirmek lazım Ve böylece
sonrasında üç yıllık bir çabanın sonunda
ne olacak hayatımdaki bilimsel tırnak
izi tezimi yazmış oldu Ondan sonra Evet
çok yaratıcı değildir bir yeryüzü
gökyüzü bir kitap olduğu için ben de
buna yeryüzünde gökyüzünde gördüklerimiz
adım taktım bu kitabı yazmanın bana ya
da işte bu tezi yazmanın bana bir
faydası oldu Ondan sonra Mesela şey
İlkokulu 5B sınıfında fen bilgisi
dersinde böyle arkanızda gördüğünüz
cinsten ışıkların resmini gösterip
öğretmeni sormuştu bir de bunu internet
öncesi Çağ olduğunu hatırlatıyorum bu
Işıklar ne ola ki diye Ben de eğer Güney
yarımkürede ise Aurora Avustralya Kuzey
yarımkürede ise Aurora borealis diye
yanıt verilmiştir Bunların ne anlama
geldiği bilmiyorsanız şaşırmayın Bence
bir faydası yok bilmem ama öyle
biliyordum yani Ondan sonra tahmin
edebileceğiniz üzere böyle olunca
ilkokuldan mezun olduğum sırada bana
böyle bir yıllık da yazmışlar Ha Burada
nasıl geçmiş anlamadım ama derslerden
matematiği sever büyüdüğünde uzay Bilgin
olmak istemektedir Ondan sonra uzay
bilgi ne demek onu
Ben diyorum ama herhalde böyle
astrofizikçi de Kozmonot gibi birşey
olsa gerek diye tahmin ediyorum duası O
yazdığım şey beni böyle bir yola sokmuş
oldu hemen arkasından orta okula
geldiğimde komodor 64 ve evde bilgisayar
oynamadım ve mahallede naylon topla top
oynamadığım zamanlarda bu benim
kitaplarını okumaya başladım Bir de sağ
olsun TRT'de açıköğretimden lisenin ya
da üniversite bir sınıfın kimya
derslerini izliyordum İngilizce'de biraz
yoruma çok iyi anlamıyordu sonra liseye
geldiğimde artık kafamda ne yapmak sizin
netleşmiş Tea fizik kimya matematik
derslerinin hepsinde her şeyi
sorguladığı mı düşünen bir öğrenciydim
hatta bunu da birkaç tane örnek verdim
işteee kimyada niye Beta bozulması hem
eksik hem artı olabiliyor diye
soruyordum veya fizikte işte bir ümmet
de attığı aldığımızda ısıtır sanız
ısıtmakta kullanılan genleşme formülü
yanlış olduğunu kendisi tutarsız
olduğunu iddia eden bir yazılar yazdım
Ondan sonra en son
bu işte Shake böyle biyoloji dersinde
bakterilerin büyümesi ile ilgili olan
matematiksel formülü daha diferansiyel
denklem dersi almadan Üstel fonksiyon
olduğunu tür edebildim Dolayısıyla
hayatım böyle bilimle doluydu ve nereye
gitmek istediğini çok iyi biliyor
gibidir üniversiteye girme zamanı
gelince isterseniz hemen bir seçim
yaptım fizik okuyacaktım buna karşılık
çevrem bana dedi ki ki bu dersleri
öğretmenleri de dahil olmak üzere ya
evladım Türkiye'de fizikçi olacaksın Ne
olacak Ondan sonra açıkçası söyleyeyim o
sırada bilmiyordum yani buna verebilecek
somutla bir atım yoktu ama gene de
inatla fiziği seviyorum ben fizik
okuyacağım diyordum derken yine bir
kareye Girdi şimdi Ortaya bir gün
Matematik Dünyası dergisinin içerisinde
çift anadal programı de bir şey olduğunu
okudum ve tekrar hayatımda istedim ki
ben artık hem ailemin istediğinizi
çevrenin ismi yapacağım hem de fizik
okuyacağım iki bölümü beraber
bitireceğim bunun içinde o diye geldim
bu ODTÜ'de bu çok güzel vakitlerimi oldu
Ondan sonra mesela naylon naylon şeyle
topla değil de tenis topuyla oturun
çimlerinde futbol oynayıp gol
attığımızda bol bol ne deniyordu timsah
dansı falan yapıyorduk Bir de onlardan
geri kalan boş zamanlarımızda böyle
Çalışkan İnek öğrenci olduğumuz için bu
resimde görüldüğü oturuyorduk
çok geç özgürlük özellikle düşük tuttum
diğer arkadaşları zor durumda bırakmamak
için ondan sonra ama hakikaten çok tatlı
arkadaşlarım vardı ve onların da
çabasıyla onlarla beraber çalışarak
hakikaten dört senede iki bölümde
bitirdim bitirdikten sonra dedim ki hadi
ben gidiyorum artık kararım net doktora
fiziğe gidiyorum artık Ailemde ayağa
fırladım Ne halin varsa gör dediler bana
Ben de kalktım sistem fırça gittim bu
arkada gördüğünüz büyük uzun şey bina
işte dünyanın en uzun lineer parçacık
hızlandırıcısı orada bar diye bir
deneyde penguen bozulmalarını çalıştım
Ne demek penguen bozulması
diyebilirsiniz fizikçilerin böyle bir
bazılarını hiç olmazsa bir PAF yanı var
gündelik hayattaki kelimeleri taşal
aştığımız şeylerin içerisine sokmayı çok
seviyoruz Bu hikayede işte feihmann
çizimleri dediğimiz bir çizimler o
çizimleri yapan bir kuramcı bir gün
kafayı çok çekip Bunlar penguene
benziyor dediği için Hadi Pen
bu kalmış Ondan sonra ileride mesela
belgesel falan yapmak isterseniz Hani ve
normal biyolojik penguenlerden çok
gösterecek kalmazsa işte buradan
belgesel yapabileceğiniz bir şey var
yani neyse ben bu penguen şeyler ölçerek
doktora tamamladım ve ondan sonra
Böylece hayatın ikinci tezini yazarak
kendimi bir kariyer çizme hazır oldu do
genellikle fizikte lisansı
bitirdiğinizde fizikçi olmasanız da
doktora bitirdiğinizde tam fizikçi
sayılırsınız Ben artık kendimi fizikçi
hissetmeye başlamıştım ve kalkıp kendimi
nerede olduğunu bir o noktada ölçe
bildim Ondan sonra bu arada ufak bir
arıza yapmışım ben uzay Bilgin olmak
istiyordum en sonda parçacık fizikçisi
oldum sadece trilyon kere trilyon kere
trilyon kat bir mertebe hatası yapmış
bulundum Ondan sonra Ama gene de hani
ana şey tutturmuş Türk mesleği onun
ardından İsviçre'ye geldim sonraki
laboratuvara işte
de Ozan'ın ve onun alternatiflerin
araştırıldığı Atlas deneyin parçası
olarak çalışmaya başladım Boş
zamanlarında artık ne tenis topuyla
neden hayvan topla futbol oynuyordum
Onun yerini söyle gelip gezmek
isteyenlere orada Kime yemekhanedeki
mıknatıslı çatal kaşıkları tanıyorduk
bayağı keyifli bir zamanım oldu Bir
yandan fizikçi olduğumu ispatla bilecek
bir şekilde saçma sapan bir kelimeyi
fizikli telefona katmak için çaba
harcadım söndü en çok sevdiğim bir
arkadaşla birlikte Bir öpeceğim diye bir
yazılım yaptık Meyhanede bizi sevilen
sözcüğünü fizikte tersine katmış olduk
Bu şekilde bir de şimdi fizikçi
olduğumuz son işareti olarak da güzel
bir şey oldu bu pürüzsüz almamın
güzelliğini ortaya çıkartmak isteyen
saçlarım geriye doğru çekilmeye
başladılar Ondan sonra artık dedim
herhalde Ben piştim Ondan sonra oldu
fizikçi E ne yapayım o zaman kalkayım
bir elektron atom vesaire konusunda
ahkam kesmeye hazırım hadi ben gideyim
Hoca olayım dedim
ve 2011'de bazı vizeye geldim 2011'de
boğaz iyice geldiğinden bu yana geçen
dokuz sene içerisinde Yalnız çok değişik
bir şey oldu bütün fiziğe bakışım Altüst
oldu bu noktaya geldiğimde artık
yapılabilecek her şeyi yaptığını
düşünüyordum Ondan sonra Fakat dersleri
vermeye başladığımda kitle derse
dediğimiz herkesin aldığı ortak fizik
dersleri özellikle vermeye başlayınca
kafamda bazı şeylerin değişik bir
şekilde oturmaya başladığını fark ettim
daha önceden görmediğim ilişkiler
görmeye başlamıştım ve bunları nasıl
oldu da bu kadar eğitimin üstünden o
zamana kadar anlayamadığını şaşırdım
Böylece yavaş yavaş yavaş yavaş gerçek
fiziğine olduğunu öğrenmeye başladım
ilginç bir şekilde doktora bitirip
postop beslenme yaptıktan sonra
gerçekleşen bir şey bu onun içinde orada
gene t19en bir tane atabilir misin gene
size bir kamera Ben bir şey para
göstermek istiyorum o karede
boğaziçi'nden diğer üç arkadaşımla kurdu
birlikte kurduğumuz bir Boğaziçi fizik
örtüsü de bir sosyal medya platformu var
O yüzden şöyle bir ekran tuz Hesabımız
var Oraya bazı arkadaşlar dediler ki
Dünya düzdür tamam mı Çok ilginç bir
şekilde o olay Şimdi size Kristalize
edeceğim ya Nasıl düşünce şeklini
değiştirdi Burada da dünyanın düz
olmadığı ile ilgili çembersel olduğu
ilgili bir sürü tabi kitaplarda
anlatılan deneyler var ondan sonra
kitaplarda anlatılan deneylerden bir
tanesi milattan önce 200 lü yıllarda
Aristoteles diye bir kişi tarafından
yapılmış bu kişi işte Bir sıcak Neyse
Haziran gününde bakmış Güneş asmanda tam
tepeden geliyor hiç gölge yaratmıyor
bundan 800 kilometre uzaktaki
iskenderiye'de ise yedi derece açılan
Güneş gölge bırakıyor bu iki bilgiyi
kullanarak arrest o mesajı Dünyanın
yuvarlak olduğunu göstermemiş Üstüne
üstlük çapını şey çevresini şu anki
modern değerinin yüzde bir yakında
düzgün bir şekilde hesaplamayı başarmış
yani bundan 2220 yıl önce birisi
halihazırda Dünya
o bile hesaplamış durumda Fakat bu düz
dünya diyen arkadaşlar Hatta olarak
bakın kesinlikle haklı olarak dediler ki
sen bu deneyi yapmadın yani aslana
gitmedin şey yapmadım direkt gitmedin
nereden belli kitapta yazan şey doğru
Ondan sonra değil ki Ayrıca diyelim ki
bu ölçü öyle yapılmış olsun aynı veri
başka şekilde yorumlamanın mümkünatı yok
mudur kesinlikle vardır ve de bunu
yapmanın basit en basit yolu bu resimde
görülüyor Güneş Burada olsun diyelim
dünyada düz eğer ki dünya güneşe yakınsa
hakikaten Aslan da hiç gölge
bırakmayacak şekilde dik gelebilir ama
işte oradan 8 kilometre uzaklıktaki
iskenderiye'de güzelce önü iz
bırakabilir burayı Haklılar Yani bu
geriye bakarak sadece Dünyanın yuvarlak
olduğu söylenemez buradan ne
söylenebilir yalnız Eğer ki bu dedikleri
doğruysa Güneş'in Dünya'ya yakın olması
gerekir Ondan sonra ben dedim ki hayır
Dünya Güneş Yakın olmaz Neden Çünkü
dünyayı ne kadar yakın olması
bu hesaplayabiliriz burası hı liseden
beri bildiğimiz geometri trigonometri
kararlarına göre şuraya hesapları Burası
yaklaşık 5000 6000 kilometre gibi bir
şey yapar 5000-6000 kilometre olursa
Güneş yani dünya falan kalmaz Yani o
kadar her tarafı yakar Ondan sonra o
zaman dediler ki Belki geometri
yanlıştır yani o geometre güvenebilir
misiniz geometri güvenmek durumundasınız
Neden gelmek durumundasınız da herhangi
bir mühendislik işi varsa köprü
yapıyorsanız yol yapıyorsanız düzgün
yapıyorsanız mecbur wendy s ihtiyacınız
var mühendise zaten hendeseden geliyor
yani geometri bilen kişi demek yönetim
eden mühendis olamazsınız O yüzden Demek
ki geometri biraz diyelim bari deyip
ondan sonra başka bir alternatif
söyleyebiliriz belki Tamam Güneş Yakın
ve de biometre doğru ama belki Güneşten
gelen Işıklar bir şekilde daha çok
yayılıyor yayıldığı için de işte Dünya
çok ısıtmıyor Ondan sonra da hemen bir
yanımız var dediğinizi mümkün olabilmesi
için yani bir bölümle kare formülü değil
de başka bir formülle gidebilmesi için
O benim üç boyutlu değil daha çok
boyutlu olması lazım bu yeni boyutları
da elimize gözümüze tutabileceğimiz
boyutlarda olması lazım dolayı da bu da
mümkün değil Yani bir formül Canım
sıkıldığı için yazmıyoruz o formülü ile
aynı zamanda Biz evinizi kaç boyutlu
olduğundan gelip üretiliyor ve o zaman
vazgeçtik diyelim ki güneş soğuktur Hani
öyle yapamazmıyız bunu da mümkün değil
Çünkü Güneş soğutmaya kalkacak olursanız
rengi sarı olmaz gitti de kırmızıya
doğru akar Hatta bu hikaye yapabilmek
istiyorsanız kızılötesini falan koymamız
lazım birbirimizi göreceğimiz kadar bir
ışık vermez Güneş uzaman değilsiniz
belki Güneşin verdiği sıcaklığıyla
verdiği rengin arasındaki ilişki yanlış
bilmiyordur bu ilişkinin yanlış
bilindiğini söylemek istersiniz bunu
bence bundan 5000 yıl önceki bronz
yağını icad eden o şey metal eriten
arkadaşlara soru onları onlar size ye
bir şey erik metalin ışığıyla rengiyle
sıcaklığın arasındaki ilişki onlar bile
söylerlerse ama onu da beğenmeyecek
olursanız 1900'lerin başında Max Planck
denilen
ben bu hesabı düzgün yapabildiği için
Kuantum mekaniği devrimi yapabildik O
zaman dersiniz ki Belki pantolona yani
yanlıştır Ondan sonra zaten ok
edilmediği falan hikaye var ya ben hiç o
zaman inanmamıştım saçma bir şey
gelmişti bu kuantum mekaniğini bırakalım
diğer misiniz eğer öyle derseniz o zaman
bir kere lazer di işte bilgisayarda
onları bir Elveda değil Ama onun
ötesinde başka bir şey daha var atom
dediğiniz şey çevresindeki elektronlar
vardı ya artık kararlı olamaz ve
içerisinde oturduğu sandalyenin içinden
geçmeye başlarsınız nefes alamazsınız
Hatta düşünemezsiniz Dolayısıyla atom
diye bir şey varsa Punto mekanı olmak
zorunda ki o kararlı olsun işte bu
noktada birisi kalkıp yedi ki belki de
atom diye bir şey yoktur atomda elektron
diye bir şey olduğunu nereden
biliyorsunuz eşine bir sürü insan
bildiğini söyledi nereden biliyorsunuz
atom ya da elektron diye bir şey
olduğunu nereden biliyorsunuz ne kadar
eminsiniz bu bilgi de onun için burada
ilginç bir noktaya gelmiş olduk Bir kere
öncelikle Benim de herşey birbiriyle
ilişkili bir
O yüzden bir taşı oynadık alanlara
sahibi tutacağım dememiz mümkün değil
ama ikinci başka bir şey daha var Her
bildiğimiz bilgi bir şeylere deneyerek
keşfettiğimiz şey eğer ki siz bir bilgi
kendiniz keşfetme değilseniz yada nasıl
çeşidini anlamadıysanız Aslında o
bilgiye sahip değilsiniz Ne o yüzden
bunu Öğrenmiş oldum ikinci Adım olarak
fizikçi hiçbir şey olduğu gibi kabul
etmez elini kirletir test eder ondan
sonra dolayı söyle kitaplardan falan
deneyi kitap okuyarak deneyi okul
içebilir öğrenmez deneyi kendiniz
yapmanız lazım şimdi onun için bunu da
yaptık Ondan sonra bu acizlikten Birkaç
arkadaşım öğrencilerimizle birlikte bir
balon aldık O balonun altına bir tane
küçük kamera koyup o balonu gökyüzüne
yolladık gökyüzünde yükseldikçe
fotoğraflarını çekti çekti çekti takipçi
iyice yerden 25 30 kilometre kadar
itfaiye geldiği noktada artık böyle Dış
dış uzayın karanlığı göre bilmeye
başladık Ve dünyanın yuvarlak olduğunu
gördük
bu Eğer şimdi bu projeksiyondan görmekte
güçlük çekiyorsunuz Ben şimdi bu
fotoğrafın kontrast ayarını birazcık
artırayım Ondan sonra net bir şekilde
yuvarlak olduğunu görebilirsiniz şimdi
Önemli olan nokta şu siz hala dünyanın
düz olduğunu mesela düşünüyor
olabilirsiniz ama o zaman bu deneyi
kendiniz yapın görmek görün diyorum ben
Yani benim dediğimi ya da göstereyim
fotoğraf at da inanmayın veriyi kendiniz
alın kendiniz deneyip yapıp sonra
söyleyeceğim şey şu fizik dediğimiz şey
bir akademik disiplin olan kısmı var
Böyle işte belgesellere duyduğunuz sizin
kuramları yok kara delikler işte bilinen
bir şey büyük hızlandırıcılar falan
filan Bunlar bayağı iyi çekebiliyor
Ondan sonra Ama bu fizik akademik
disiplin olan kısmı Bir de fiziği
gerçekte fizik yapan bir şey var Her
akyanın fizikçi Akademisi olmak zorunda
değil akademisyenler fizikçi olmak
zorunda değil Bu ne demek Bu da şu temel
fiziğin içerisinde de inanılmaz
bir şeyler var bu yansı en kolay
hazırlığım yansı oldu buradaki
fotoğrafların hepsi benim normal 1.
sınıf 2. sınıf derslerinde gösterdiği
fotoğraflardan fizik size mesela karate
yaptırabilir fizik size daha iyi üçlük
atış yaptırabilir fizik meksi kadar
olimpiyatlarda size altın madalya
kazandırabilir fiziği doğru anlarsanız
bir Balen olarak havada daha güzel
kalabilirsiniz fizik size dans
ettirebilir fizik motosikletin tepede
takla atıp doğru şekilde aşağı inmesini
sağlayabilir fizik ham elması yüzünüzün
üzerine koyacağınız tektaş pırlanta
dönüştürebilir fizik İlizyon yapmanızı
sağlayabilir fizik 2000-3000 yıllık
arkeolojik gizemleri çözmenizi sağlanır
Bunların hepsi burada söyleyeyim fiziğin
hepsi lise veya üniversite nin 1. sınıf
seviyesindeki Fizikle ve bunlarda
inanılmaz keyifli ve bunlar da elinizin
altına koyduğunuz da kullanabileceğiniz
şeyler diyebilirsiniz gibi buna ne hiç
görmedik niye böyle öğrenmedik falan
diye
Ya ben işte bu noktada hikayenin son
noktasına gelmiş olur niye tekil bir
hikaye anlatır niye kendi hikayemi
Hikayem çok basit Aslında 89 yaşında
böyle bir konuya ilgi gösteren birisi
bile bütün akademik kariyerini bu işleri
düzgün öğreneceğim diye getirip de işte
Bilmem son gibi dünyanın en üst
laboratuvar lan biz de çalıştığı halde
şu olayın keyfini Ancak son On senede
anlayabildiği Sen Eğitim sistemimizin ne
kadar ezberci olduğunu Hayal etmenizi
istiyorum Yani bütün bu işe bütün
hayatını vermiş en çok bunu yapmak
istiyorum diyen birisi bile Eğer
anlayamadı ysa bu işin keyfini normal
eğitim süreci içerisinde Demek ki bizim
insanlar ürettiğimiz fizik gerçek fizik
değil Dolayısıyla Sağlıcakla kalın
araştırın öğrenin ve de atoniye var Bir
bakın öğrenin